hey guys this is gonna be a very short
video this week because my body has
decided that now is the best time it
could possibly picked you couldn't tract
the world's worst cold and starches
glorious so doesn't actually have much
to talk about this week because I spent
most of the week lying in bed feeling
like that the only footage I have to
speak of is me working in the library
incidentally sixth week is suit week and
me going to visit university parks
because moments looking very old
terminal and very pretty
university parks is one of the things
that I can go into free anybody can
guarantee for free so by the Uni and
maintained by the Union you get a sport
happening there like lacrosse as I said
this was blues lacrosse match that was
going on out there realize it was
probably a bit creeping me turning up
and his filming girls and shorts just
like you know I was dressing the scene
at the lab I was like dressed in a suit
filming girls doing across not actually
like that I was just getting a picture
of the park but girls happened to be in
the way
actually it was on that day that I
bumped into Andrew Wiles of Fermat's
Last Theorem thing he's teaching Ashley
identify his teaching he's at the Uni at
the moment he did his undergrad here in
his back I said I think he's back at
Merton college might be wrong but it was
strange because I was watching Fermat's
Last Theorem the day before and then
bumped into him in like just outside uni
parks which is a bit strange but hey
Oxford so yeah I do not have the energy
to have proper video this week or to be
honest the material so the room tour is
gonna have to wait till next week though
if you have a hankering to see one
Oxford room looks like I direct you to
the already excellent room tour that was
done by another Oxford youtuber called
Jamie Mills who is a second year PP
student at modeling college
so check out his video which I'll put a
link to in the description or we can
probably click some on the screen upper
link which you should definitely look at
because he's going to do a lot better
than I will ever do now next week is my
seventh week flowing it's the
penultimate one of the of the series and
I want to do a Q&A session in at some
point either in seventh or eighth week
most likely because seventh week is
gonna be held because I already have to
do a lot of work
last week's worth of work as well but at
some point I would like to do a video
about interviews like questions related
to Oxford interview so please leave in
the comment section below
any questions that you have about the
Oxford interview whether that is my
interview experience what it's like to
do a general interview anything you
should bring what you should prepare
leave a comment and I will do another
Q&A type video I'm asking this because
I'm actually help you out with
interviews this season in Oxford some
Peters college so I thought if I get
people's common questions now that's my
phone I thought that if I could get
people's comm questions now then I'm I'd
been prepared for it for helping people
with interview and you the audience are
better prepared as well so whether
you're gonna be coming out to Oxford a
French for you this year or in years to
come leave a comment I will do my best
to answer all your question right I'm
going back to bed
see you next week